each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's my pleasure to introduce
Vladimir you H yes he is no Bush's
brother I think the question everybody
asks Vladimir is not new to Microsoft he
was actually a developer here for
several years yeah a couple couple years
and he recognized that what he really
wants to do is research and he went back
to Toronto and is just finishing his PhD
they're working with Brendan fray and
other people and some of you may know
Vladimir when he was here as a fellow
he's a microsoft research fellow and he
worked with Chris and Carl and nuh
Borgia and myself on the HIV vaccine
design but that's not what he's going to
talk about today he's going to talk
about some other work that he's done
since then it's a little bit of it at
Microsoft yes a little bit elsewhere so
Vladimir take it away thank you thank
you so as they've mentioned there has
been I've done a bit of well most of the
work I have done during my graduate
studies was basically in conversational
biology some ways here somewhere the
University of Toronto they've mentioned
the HIV vaccines but there's a
phylogenetic trees help the block
analysis and a couple of other topics
but today I'm going to talk about some
different problems which also benefit
from the machine learning techniques
essentially this poem of self-assembly
which is a problem from essentially
chemistry on technology and also
computer science bowl move automatically
inferring programs formed up in put out
examples
so for the for the so they're basically
essentially two parts of the talk the
first part arc is but the self-assembly
and the methods for assessment and
design of self assembly processes second
part is going to focus on the
approximate difference for the problem
of inferring programs from input and
output pairs so for the self-assembly a
problem or the self-assembly mechanism
it is quite important in the area of now
technology where synthesis of compounds
or is basically the end goal for all the
efforts but that particular synthesis of
compounds is basically difficult to be
too to achieve in the sense that we
actually build other things because we
don't have access on nano scale we don't
have small tools which we can actually
use to get to the nanoscale to sample
compounds or I thought at that level so
what people have been thinking about and
method that an approach that has been
basically applied this to this problem
of synthesizing small compounds nano
sized compounds is to basically have
them self assemble so if you can
actually choose the correct species
molecular species what will occur that
they will actually self assemble in the
compound of your interest the one that
you're actually targeting and the
motivation for actually taking this
approach came from biology where this is
happening constantly it certainly the
example that people are most familiar
with is basically RNA of protein folding
in the information of the complexes but
also one interesting example is the
viral capsid assembly where multiple
proteins are actually but actually a
large number of copies of multiple
proteins multiple species types of
proteins are actually assembled into a
capsid which envelops the virus and
actually is very important functionally
important to enable the virus to
actually enter the cell it is going to
attack
but when you step back and take a look
at what the problem what the problem but
the essential mechanism is all about the
self-assembly mechanism what is what is
this process what is the essence of this
process it is really just convergence of
the distribution of the states to the
acceleration liberation of the of the
system convergence to the equilibria
distribution Boltzmann distribution so
that if you start from sum up let's
start from uniform distribution of
overall all the states and you proceed
to equilibrium it will basically
converge to the to the Boltzmann
distribution and this is a known fact
from the statistical mechanics and
thermodynamics so what happy to humans
has self-assembly is nothing more than
actually convergence to this
distribution and the expression of the
particular types of states according to
probability on this distribution so a
shape that we would think that has
self-assembled is actually just mode of
this distribution pronounced mode but
more than less so that's our chance that
the ways we actually almost explicitly
says how we actually go about designing
cells and processes and just to serve
drill down a little bit to the
application side of the self-assembly
and then now technology there's there's
been quite a bit of interest in the
manufacture of carbon nanotubes and
their application their various
applications for the carbon nanotubes
from the academic having them act as
reinforcement agents to nano electronics
and finally using them this is of course
these are just examples there's quite a
bit more but the one example is
controlled the drug release into the
bloodstream so you can there is quite a
bit of applications you can for for you
can actually refer to the science
article but then the question is if
since the nanotubes are so great how do
we produce them in large quantities and
recently in 2004 science article by Hill
at all considered one self a semi
process they picked the core
molecules there that we picked up
correct of course they have carbon but
they attach the pro correct molecules
though the carbon so that it would
actually guide the assembly into then
out into the carbon nanotubes and there
was a high particle in science as well
that serve hyped up the original server
there's a company article so nicely
summarized in my opinion what the actual
approach takes and also the essence of
the self-assembly design for the
self-assembly and that is that you
actually have to controlled
intermolecular and remember mental
forces so that you can actually produce
the compounds of interest in large
quantities another serve example in
biology where the self-assembled curso
and varied on various scales in the
various times but the nice example is
assembly of the viral capsids which
again enveloped the virus and protected
from the basically maintain the
consistency virus and inside you have
there's viral proteins in RNA back then
so what you can see is that the for the
for this particular virus you can
actually see that there are three types
of proteins which are basically in
certain qualities which are assembled
into this capsule and there's that has
recently been quite a bit of interest in
simulating the Assembly of the capsid
and actually this year only this year
alone up to sir from january till now
there there have been five papers
published about assembling different
capsule some with different viruses this
is up interesting the fact they were
five papers basically hints at or server
implies that they're very efficient
inference techniques mostly based on
molecular dynamics that can actually be
used to simulate the assembly so that's
because we're going to be dealing with
the inference later and it's it's
hardened to know that even on this scale
difference is possible and for the more
you know the assembly thats in the
simulation assembly is fairly accurate
considering nakano technologies are
filled up it was just another field
where machine learning can
very fruitful II applied aside from the
just designing the process for
self-assembly we the nanotechnology
community is not at the point they
actually started to produce quite a bit
of data similar to the biology turns
that were actually occurring I'm still
occurring there quite a bit of data is
being produced and it's quite more it's
a bit more sophisticated than what you
get from say microarray in that the
actual snapshots of now full
distribution of the states or for the
distribution of the states of a system
can be actually obtained so to see the
scanning electron microscope you can
actually get the snapshot down to a
fairly high resolution of what is going
on so you can actually these the level
blobs here are the about 10 nanometer in
radius gold nanoparticles so that's
pretty that's pretty that's pretty high
resolution so you can actually get a
snapshot of what happens in the system
there are other examples other
measurement methods that the chemists
are using one of the interesting thing
is but when you get to this level this
the to such a low level such small
particles that even the color of the
solution water solution has got world on
our particles can indicate how what are
the size the sizes of the aggregates so
you can actually infer the radius of how
big an argue how big our gates are ones
they're occurring the water solution and
additional methods were actually the the
distribution of the sizes of the Argus
can be found out so all this method
although this experimental experimental
measurements can be actually used to
improve our get a better potential there
for the energies of the states that can
be actually used to do perform to do
better in France typically do barriers
that we can do simulation and we don't
we're not necessarily reliant on the
question
okay so why okay so essentially what we
want to do is find the best possible
potentials so we can actually perform
efficient actually exact correct SS
corrected as correct as possible
inference and use this potential
selection the particular is going to
happen once all these particles are put
in water solution and of course finally
the ultimate sort of holy grail of all
this work is essentially to close the
loop so to automate the synthesis of the
particles measurements and then the
inference as well so that we can
actually without that so we can actually
leverage the indices sooner sorry
leverage the measurements in such a way
that we both improve our inference and
improve our design if we can add
automate the whole whole loop in a sense
where we can actually change the
synthesis of the particles which are
slightly perturbed from the previous
iteration and automatically measure and
make inference help we can actually
improve the choice of particles so as to
obtain a particular goal say that we
want to produce particular shape or want
to have capsid like assembly then we we
can close the loop and eliminate humans
completely out of the necessity of
dealing with trying to serve up act
serve optimizers on this on this on this
problem oh ok I'm a skeptic on
everything and thus on this as well so
at least to it I don't understand all
the applications this but two of them I
understand well enough to have to be
skeptical about so one why do I care how
a virus itself is
why do you care so you can actually
first appropriate a pre-emptive answer
to a question you didn't ask I'm just
that the whole story about the Assembly
of the caps it is there to say that we
can efficiently we can do good inference
about the Assembly of the virus why you
care if so aside why would you care
about this is that if you can actually
obstruct the Assembly of the virus you
will abstract this integration of the
virus and they will not get the healthy
virus coming out of the cell so if you
are not saying that you should be
interested in how tall the assembly
essentially operates but people who are
interested I interested both for the
reasons of demonstrating that they can
actually similarly correctly so they can
discover the end the second one is
potential applications in medicine so if
you can abstract and it's into the
creation of any any any kind of oil you
know assembly of the virus you're in
good shape to actually prevent it sir
production so okay you also talk about a
slow release of drugs as an application
it seems that that's something you know
you just coat your dragon nothing that
dissolve slowly ah right but this is
over over time so you basically you you
deliver quite a bit of drug and you want
the slow release of the drug is all
slowly as like a unit betting it in a
magician i thought i'm not i'm not
arguing that this is necessarily the
best way to do it is just one of the
applications for the material i'm sure
that though i'm not saying that
nanotubes are necessarily the best way
for the releasing the drugs point taken
but it's the one that's basically are
the best way to do anything i mean i
don't the other two applications they
don't understand well your isolation
yeah for nanoelectronics yes because
they're great probably a solution for
the 44 nanowires so yeah you want to
basically isolate none of ours you would
make sure that they're safe thing
separate so yeah you do want to you
won't have some kind of isolation
between the device is that assuming you
have
this is assuming suffered massive
Assembly of it is it is Sir futuristic
in a sense that there aren't that many
nano electronic devices right now so
that we really need to make the virus as
good as possible and so on and so on and
we make a this is all in a sense people
are exploring the building bits of
electronic devices that need to be
possible to make in order to make an an
electronic device Oh Olli yeah we we
build computer chips today very very
small scales without this kind of
technique dial yeah we're building
trypsin this is soon floor essentially
we / you just will let you build a much
much right yeah no carbon nanotube is
basically a layer of single carbon atoms
basically going around in radius so it's
not like you have many carbon atoms
sitting it's basically single it's
single wall no not much on phone okay
and then and then this would help you
don't assemble the wires and right Ohio
to those wires and financial devices is
a open from often problem but it's also
one that it can be that's where i talk
about self-assembly it's the same thing
how can i get things to get into the
state into the place in space where I
want them so they also can be formulated
as a what's the program on the maximum
probability there's all those virus a
basic aligned how they do that I mean
yeah well be super maximize the
probability you pick how you're going to
decorate the nanotubes water water
molecules are going to put on the side
on the nanotubes so that they would
basically assemble in some some some
alignment that you like so in a sense
the phone exactly problem you're talking
about is the promo of the self-assembly
any kind of alignment any kind of setup
of the molecules is basically answer
over by cell by self-assembly that's why
it's important because the bottom-up
technique for achieving the goals a
document now I'm not going to tell you
that I'm not a nanotube experts are not
going to try to sell you should be using
the on tips for everything carbon
nanotubes there possibly better ways to
do are any of those bones but not
necessarily at that scale
hierarchical iterate sovereign so you
want to have you want to figure out
first how by just controlling the
consideration of different particles you
can increase the probability of having
putzie nanotubes but then once you have
punished you can LOL so somebody is a
probability of right oh it's not right
but you have to know teachers like that
not there know what actually happens is
the people the one example that serves
as fairly it's done over and over again
is to basically take take a molecule
stick a DNA chain on it and then find
out more like you'll stick analogy NHO a
compound by another molecule and mark or
an assembly you're basically stick
computer or compatible DNA strands and
you have them hybridize and so you
basically in a sense you can organize
things but you have to start thinking
about this from the bottom from the
beginning right if you're going to have
a hierarchical design you have to put
all the all the bits and pieces right
there from the beginning right once your
mother things example you're not going
to be able to attach another molecule
there so for seeing how you're going to
use your building blocks is important
finding as well these are thousand
different times that is true to you is
automatically a different time right but
in here i'll be talking just about the
equilibrium written by deliberate yeah
in the first in the first first three
there is no not there is no outside
fields there's no generic no spikes in
temperature there's no there's no timing
as such you're basically expecting that
you have sufficient amount time to
equilibrate the system but yes if you
wanted to that the tricky part about
that serve getting ahead of myself but
take tricky part of that of
non-equilibrium submissions is that we
don't have a closed form solution for it
we have multiple solution for this this
concept or before the nonequilibrium
decisions we don't have a closed form so
you actually have to sample there to
actually computing derivatives vid it
gets kind of tricky but the point is
that essentially there is plenty of room
for similar to the serve computational
biology efforts which are basically
analyze that all kinds of different
sources of data chemistry on technology
have comparable wide range of methods
they can be they're actually being used
all the time and their their information
is being derived for them by people in
the labs and there's quite a bit of
opportunity for machine learning and
computer vision obviously contributions
so so the questions now is if we're
going to play around with the idea of
self-assembly and we're going to try to
derive algorithms we need that there is
quite a bit of complexity involved and
similarly how to carbon molecules
interact or carbon three car bombs
interact or if you have large large
nanoparticles and then they may have
peptides that's quite a bit of atoms so
it's the question is can we find the
cavity have postulate model simple model
in which we can actually investigate all
the aspects they are necessary for a
particular problem without having to
actually model every single counted
every single atom and actually deal with
the certainty Gritty of actually we're
presenting the physical realism so what
we were looking for or what i was
looking here for here is the simplest
possible model which i can actually
replicate some of the aspects but still
perform still analyze performance of the
algorithms so what I'm saying is I'm not
going to simulate for you carbon
nanotubes or the capsid assembly the
capsid if because simply that is too
expensive and the guys for actually
doing that they're running the the
tobacco virus was actually run at the ua
you see in using the ncsa machines and
grant over I believe 50 days so it takes
a while to actually do this exactly so
the simple model is basically we're
going to take a 2d lattice of the finite
and the finite volume and we're going to
sets it and find a number of particles
on this on this on the sites in the
lattice each particle has particular
species assigned to it so it's a
particular type the reason that we that
we serve have a predetermined number of
species and temperature is fixed and the
reason why I'm serve listening this
service it might seem odd if you're not
familiar with the computational
chemistry computational physics are the
server n VT ensemble is just one of the
examples that people use to study
behaviour of systems essentially it what
it boils down to is the distribution
over the over the states in this end
sample is basically the bottom
distribution a couple of other ensembles
most notably or service ly informative
if you if you haven't heard what this
stuff is the molecular dynamics methods
operating the mve ensemble so they're
the number of particles and the volume
or fix and the energy is being is fixed
so they'll be basically moving along the
lines of the fixed energy and that's why
you have the trade-off between potential
and kinetic energy anyway so that's just
an informative there a couple of other
the grand canonical ensemble or you can
actually even vary the number of
particles but you have to have different
kind of potentials for our purposes this
is serve a deal because we have together
Boltzmann distribution out of it easily
and we can we don't have to care we will
assume that we have fixed number of
particles it's not that they could make
an assumption for us especially at this
stage so
an example is this 505 lat us with a
particles each particles of particular
species so we have evenly divided this
is the particles between the two species
so X number of particles anything fixed
number of a number of power particles in
fixing numbers numbers for species right
and no other stream we are now reserved
adding the energy energy that the air
because we were working with the bottom
of the special meal at the start
describe the energy and actually the
bottom of this official falls up when we
have a very large lattice so we would
what you would actually do with the
people essentially deal with this kind
of issues by introducing periodic
boundary conditions that you have
essentially a modeling a very large
number of replications of the same
system in a sense but it's really
modeling a large fairly large ensemble
infinite lattice is basically produced
by this periodic conditions so I'm going
to associate some potentials we'd
interact with the with for with
interactions of particles so essentially
if the particles are on the neighboring
somebody sighing maybe there's a
question if you have two particles
placed on the lattice in neighbouring
sites then their charges in a between
input in neighboring charges come into
contact and we were associating four
charges with each of the direction so
each particle has a charge north east
south and north south east and west so
in a sense in the first is first in the
first interaction you'll basically have
the charges on the east of the particle
of species one is interacting with the
charges on the west side of particle
species species number two so it's
actually and to get the energy of the
four full configuration is basically
integrate over all the all the all the
pairs of particles that are neighboring
states
neighbouring sites apologies and that
that gives you essentially the energy
expression so now the question is what
is that we are actually you got the
small what is very actually trying to
achieve so the self-assembly problem all
self-assembly mechanisms are meant
essentially to produce compounds or
particular shape like the viral capsid
or like a carbon nanotube so if you're
given the desire desire the shap shape
and a set of particles where we actually
pick the pick the set of particles we
actually would like to compute how often
would this assemble into this desired
state so I said me and if you put this
in the circle now we actually step into
the Boltzmann distribution all you want
to actually compute this this partition
function over here which is where so the
songs running of all the all the all the
states that are in the shape like that
one and divided over the way the
petition fraction where the Sun is
running over all possible states so
we're actually pursuing the problem of
computing ratios or partition functions
pretty standard problem or at least he
has the flavor a pretty standard of
control as will become obvious in a
second why it's just the shade of the
flavor so the question now is since
we're going to compare methods we want
basically a baseline and we if possible
want to exact baseline and one of the
reasons to actually choosing simple
models that such as lattice and limiting
ourselves so small ladders is the
reactor actually can compute exactly
partition functions fairly efficiently
the constraint though is that we have
the fixed number of particles so the
whole grid we should have only finite
number of particles in each and in our
particular species so the question is
how do we do how do we do inference that
we all actually how do we compute the
partition function and there is a fairly
simple dynamic program that can be you
actually used to
to compute this and the setup is the
following again we have this lattice and
this is served up standard trick for the
for the grid in MRFs how you would
actually marginalize the distribution
area to actually compute a petition
fraction if you wanted to you're
basically collapse all the variables
associated with the with the particular
slice on the lattice into a single
variable a little bit fairly high
dimensional variable and then you face
free to those problems is outer
protective all yeah that's why I saying
its exact that the we were just it's we
want to compute something that's
difficult to compute to begin without
the comp constraints and I'm just saying
well once we are because calculator to
calculate seems that we're going to
basically couple the Vario variables
together because I'm saying you have to
have eight particles here so it's not
independent if you ignore the counts
it's on the pan it's that we basically
depend how many particles are left to
you but there is a fairly efficient
trick to actually deal with the
constraints as well and that is to set
up this chain with you see on top we're
actually not only carrying the variables
wise which are the slice the slice
variables by you're also carrying the
counts they're counting how many
particles in particular species have
occurred and you basically clamp the
beginning in the end beginning zeros and
for push your forward pass through and
you're done and position so I'll see it
there but it's pretty obvious how you
can actually do it position obviously is
over the whole the final form is over
the whole whole variable which includes
the count constraint cut the count
variables the Hit sir what the quota
current count variables and sliced
variables so
particles that are not adjacent are not
interacting is right i forgot to mention
that thank you for your money yes and
the reason why I'm assuming that well to
be honest otherwise it's impossible
anyways if possible but it turns out and
I did it initially because for that
reason find the poem we can actually
solve but it turns out that this is not
chemically it's not actually bad idea to
assume this because and I found that
after the fact that these guys they're
in university of liverpool co actually
building is called manar particles and
putting them in war and dissolving one
not dissolving a putting green water
which has some salt concentration so
what happens is there's a lot of ions
flying around a floating around so when
you went to particles is officially far
apart and not very much far apart
they're all this intervening ions
they're actually screening interaction
so this guy over the on Sarah further
away does not even know that there is
anything like a couple hundred meters to
the left so it's and actually that also
has implications on aggregation or
golden are particles but but Sir ads are
additional aspect of realism to the mall
will be after the fact
we're using it as exactly when I
integrate over the last eight but if
it's fuzzy would it be more if it's
probabilistic but it'd be more will it
blend itself the world uh yeah you can
election to the musician you don't exist
I mean conference train is a very it
doesn't matter yesterday as a matter if
you want the model so it's a question of
inference is a question of modeling if
you wanted to mall then you want to
model mixing proportions then yeah we're
not modern Olympics important because
that would violate their n VT ensemble
we have to go to give sample and has it
has completely different set of problems
but in this setup it's pretty much count
is set just a number of particles that
actually add it up it actually landed on
the sites instead it always it ok it's
just sorry for not being clear I I serve
talked about can't go side so many times
that it actually gets a assume everybody
understands it knows ah the whole point
of the constraint is basically going to
get to slice how many guys here we used
up by now so that's all there is that
and transition is that simple you just
calculate how many head into the
particular slice and it out by the way I
mean I should I should make the
references so so there's David first
injustice wrong at you are in the
applications of the applied to basically
be busy nuts and trying for mole
selection or learning models of data and
Quade and Brandon applied this method to
serve a different counting method to a
different problem of the protein-protein
interaction network de-noising so there
that's it's quite a it's a quite nice
trick if you have referring to this this
kind of setup so now i remember i know i
shouldn't say recall but do recall that
we actually want to compute the ratio
partition functions out the ratio
normalization constant and the basic
very basic approach to actually do this
is based on important sampling we're
essentially if if i read out this whole
setup reserve
we start off with desired quantity
divided by the various various
distribution f f of X because some of if
you can integrate integrate over X G of
X is just partition function so we're
just going to divide and multiply then
we get nice expectation because f of X
over the partition function is just the
distribution just probability of X on
the distribution F you get this nice
expectation we're now expectation land
which means that we can compute things
with the Markov chain Monte Carlo so
we're just going to go sample from F
sample plenty of samples and then just
average out the this ratio the weight so
that's pretty standard important
important sample sampling trick the
deserve the the one that and it doesn't
require us to have any kind of
normalization constant or anything
neither of these distributions has to be
normalized in order for this to work out
there's there are more sophisticated
methods of course for since there's been
quite a quite a bit of interest in this
problem because the invasion statistics
in chemistry and computational physics
there but it's basically interested in
11 sort of indifferent formulate
different different formulations of the
problem but they're basically all
reduced to that to the ratio of which
functions of a ratio of a normalization
constant and the different methods of
the red bridge sampling which Attila's
is an helpful for helping bridge
distribution which i'll serve relate to
later on path sampling which sir tries
to connect two distributions of interest
in case this gnf via some Interpol or
interpolating distributions and for my
tour dynamic litigation which code also
goes along the same lines but then
performs the numeric integration these
are that there's plenty of them and I'll
address how and when and why or why not
they cannot be applied to this to this
method and more recently there's been
the kneeled important sampling 498 now
to consider the gold standard for
evaluation of the likelihoods or the
ratio of noise ation constants
to some extent something superseded by
this nasad sampling and its really serve
a more recent introduction although it's
quite demanding ins in on the problems
it can be actually because it squares
are quite restricted so the problems
they can be applied to and this is not
one of them but I'll serve at the end of
the the whole thing I can basically tell
you more about that sound like if you're
interested but let us proceed with the
methods that are actually applicable
they can actually be applied in this
context and most of them actually are
relying on this interpolating
distributions even the bridge sampling
which there pulls on and pulls in an
arbitrary distribution most often and
the optimal solutions in general are
basically these geometric averages
between the two distributions so what
you actually do is that you try to build
you build up a sequence of this
distribution is QX which are basically
just dramatic averages of the two
distributions and you're going to use
them to interpolate between the between
the two distributions F and G I'll share
in a second how actually to do that for
in in a complex level for example on
newly important sampling but the
important assumption is that the two
distributions effigy have the same
support so it's actually that they have
positive probability assigned to the
same set
and just as illustration how you can
have this is basically how you would
actually use the dis interpolating
distributions to actually compute the
ratio of normalizing constants just to
basically make it clear so we I want to
compute the ratio of partition functions
between of distribution G and F and
we're going to basically do that by
utilizing the city of piloting set of
interpolating distributions of finite
set of interpolating distributions which
is basically just geometric average
a--'s and what we do is basically one
would start in this case start sampling
from distribution F sample sample sample
you obtain a sample from the from
distribution F then compute the ratio of
probability under the next distribution
in this interpolating chain of
distributions and F and that is your
first term here in this product so going
to accumulate this product and it
basically looks like it's it's
essentially when you actually write
write this as it looks exactly as the
important sampling over only over large
number of a large number of a
distribution so each distribution in
turn is being a proposal distribution
for the next one next interpolating
distribution in the sequence yes salute
those aren't the action
I normalized yeah yeah wouldn't they end
up being a nomination of the student not
mixture
it the matlab point-wise product you
know very little room for error what is
interesting is that basically they're
shifting support you're basically
shifting you're shifting mass slowly
from one distribution to another and you
basically correct collecting the ratios
or the energy differences if you are in
the log domain between the samples the
sample from different from distribution
so basically take difference of energy
of the samp for the sample from the
solution you've got that sample from and
the next distribution in the interchain
direction and stole everything it is so
I didn't realize that poverty today's
the day that I was thinking with
is that is that really the behavior you
want to because it seems like if you are
shifting from a mode where things fall
in like if it's kind of a you know a
surgical physics kind of problem where
you like this mode here in that mode
there it seems that a more realistic
representation of a mixture of something
in between those we have some
probability mass chance and providing us
there where's the probability mass being
in the center might make no sense at all
mom yeah you could try to do that it's
actually shown that these are optimal
these are there actually proves for the
for the bridging the submission these
are actually optimal choices in terms of
variance of the estimated blah so but
that is a good point and and the reason
why that's a good point and where where
is actually where these interpreting
distributions of the standard way there
certainly this this way actually fail is
if we suddenly have different support so
actually we're just basically going to
take the g distribution cut off at zero
play everything below is is has not
probability and now we start
constructing our interpolating
distributions unnormalized and then we
had this nice little spike over there
we're actually they're normalized
otherwise you wouldn't get the spike but
we have a cut-off here so if we apply
the same method that we actually were
using in the previous slide and we start
computing the same quantity there it is
below there i sample from fi signed by
most likely i'm here i move on to the
next inter poisson distribution i
compute this factor here at zero so i
spent all this time to sample from nice
to get a nice little sample from
distribution F want me to throw it away
how am I going to use they get a sample
that's really good well as often as you
get over here so you're actually you're
actually asking a question about how
often if I sample this distribution will
I or actually run this Markov chain will
actually enter the area that that's
supported by distribution do you want
that's that's depending on the phone
that's horribly ad ID yet to do
so okay so we're going to we're going to
have to do something else all this but
it's not I mean there are obvious
solutions right away one idea is to
basically we're still we're still in
this domain of computing ratios right
but if we are actually computing ratio
of a distribution half its interior
distribution taralyn sense that we can
actually compute this partition function
fairly easily then we once you obtain
that ratio and multiply but it's
typically computable destruction for
this easy distribution we can get back
just the normalization constant and this
is a trick that you would actually use
if you're just interested in signal
normalization constant you just pick
something easy and what you pick it
would probably pick you from
distribution or you might pick you
Cassie I miss why are we suddenly
dealing with the distributions that have
zero support
I thought the energy function because we
restricted ourselves to them through
that
did I say that I be justified just to
make sure that I sequencing of the
slides is yeah here we go I'm always
worried i got the ordering wrong f is
the full distribution on all the states
g is distribution of the in shape it has
only support in the in shape under the
on the debt under G something that's out
of the shape does it has no probability
whatsoever that make sense
yeah I define this distribution right
right right because this is what I care
I care about the probability of a subset
so it's essentially the problem of
computer probability us options are
subset on the unnormalized distribution
and all I'm saying so far is that we if
you go and then blindly naively happily
whatever applied the existing methods
you're in trouble so we have to
reconsider but it's not that difficult
to actually get something that actually
does very fairly decently the what
you'll have to do is basically change
the problem and say well okay again i'm
going to estimate these guys separately
and now it's easy you just give me a
distribution that has that it's easy to
compute and it's easy for us to compete
for the for example for the lattice
falls it's fairly easy for us to count
for distribution thats easy to compute
like you like assigning every
configuration energy 0 and then that
distribution has a potential function or
just count of possible states right
because we're summing over all the
states e to the 0 just someone's easy
partition function furthermore we can
actually compute that ratio fairly easy
fairly fairly efficiently it served has
now that we're actually using i fused
annual report example we are actually
integrating from uniform distribution to
a distribution has non non zero energies
so we're actually going to get on our
bonus is that we're going to get
slightly more efficient sampling because
of this annealing effects it's not such
a bad idea and the other thing is just
well the only problem we're having
essentially is that the support is
different so we're just going to make
support to say until separately then
then how sensitive are using the ratios
before you want to see ya variants the
separately variance is bad yeah so I
don't do it you actually want to what
you want essentially serve hand waving
waving what you want to do is basically
take the suit distributions align their
states as much as possible without
biasing your sample and their states
with the high with Sir compare Lee close
energies so that that somewhere you're
going over doesn't have outrageous
values so you're not dividing something
but if I small small small value or
dividing line some something big with
them they don't have huge variance in
this way to their
so showing so essentially but if you're
not able to do that then you have to do
separately and the variances are
basically in coming separately into into
both estimates going to address that or
it just like that just works anymore
anyways that's that's just another way I
mean we're trying so here's that here's
the serve an overview what's going on
there is a method which seems silly
separate computation and then we're
trying to actually use something more
intelligent by growing support and the
idea again just served to review what's
going on we have a distribution F with
the heat map obviously representing the
the probability mass of being assigned
distribution grid which is the service
restricted to particular set a and then
we're going to be smart or more or less
smart and we're just going to populate
this area with the copies of
distribution which is going to assign
probability mass which is basically a
copy of of probability mass is being
assigned to set a of course feel
slightly dependent on the fact that we
can actually do this in an integral
number of component so you have see you
can just your the size of this set if
we're talking about discrete
distribution has to serve divided the
size of size of the original set pass
but what's in what's we or do you just
decide now you have to be careful about
what you're going to pick and I'm going
to show what the pic for the latin small
what's important though what's the
what's the saving grace of this or the
important selling features that this
distribution has the support wherever f
has and its petition function is
multiplayer is basically the same as the
petition function of this guy x some
constant about how many times we
actually replicated
so that's the gist of it now we're
actually I mean the essential idea how
to actually solve this kind of problem
and just serve to serve slightly review
always go what's going on so we're
basically the first method this to Ira
is is basically two different separate
annealed apart sampling applications to
compute separately petition fraction I
of F put this fraction ergy that's what
we're talking about now if you can
actually find a mapping that map's the
states normal states to in shape or
actually set of all states in to
initiate states in shape states
uniformly so that we have a nice the
nice visibility constraint so there is
an integral number of copies then we can
actually do two things we can actually
then we can actually construct the g
prime a corresponding to what i've shown
in last slide and we can compute ratios
as a deaf sorry for this fraction I are
a fan but this fraction of G prime which
basically been divided by a constant is
just the partition function of F and
petition for energy or we can be just
careless and say well forget about a s
oldest interpreter scheduled why do I
bother with that that just let us do
that I just did a simple as possible
thing which is sample distribution app
and immediately switch deterministically
to a sample the in distribution g on
this map
does that make sense or do I have to
support extension
yes support extension just tells the
product second group treats a support
accession of us which is the same thing
there is this mapping only in different
ways they can be made similar I mean I
can serve a fast which is is essentially
this method without having a temper
schedule just switching immediately
without having any intermediate solution
committee distributions
so the question is well if you try all
this I mean you know to actually do the
performance mapping from phone
configurations to configure out to we
need to discuss a configuration mapping
from any old normal configurations in
shape configuration so how we're going
to do it well if you take a look at that
particular configuration you'll see that
in essentially where you can factorize
it's a representation into which sites
are occupied and then an ordering of
particle oil particle species she had
you actually go and scan this
configuration and figure figure out
what's the particular permutation
species a given occupation would define
a configuration but since for in shape
configuration we only have one
occupation set up it just has to be in
this particular shape so it turns out
that we actually I actually fairly
easily map any configuration into in
shape configuration we're just pulling
out the permutation furthermore
obviously there's there's a there's a
constant there was mentioning a previous
slide and that's just basically the
ratio that the total number of in shape
configuration in shape occupation sites
so we can ship this guy around right and
dividing by that total number of
possible occupation configurations so
Aaron question is put all these methods
basically to a test and the way we're
going to test them is we're going to
remember there's there we have the
Thetas in our models which basically
charges in different directions on the
lattice so we're just going to basically
run sample a bunch of these charges
charge assignments and try and see how
the actual methods perform in estimating
ratios compared to the exact method that
shown earlier so we have we don't have a
gold standard we have exact answer and
we're just going to say how well we're
doing so there are a couple of things
here to to bring up first of all it's
fairly easy to do well when your charges
are close
zero so basically a close the unit from
the situation no surprise there all
these methods are comparable slight
differences as your charges get with
variance of the normal distribution gets
higher than we actually are getting more
reasonable more easily we always have
all the shapes right distribution just
that I mean entropy will be higher so
what you ask yes I know attribute will
be lower as I just look yes what you
would like to get a specific shape yes
so that the entropy is Laura basically
the uniform which serve brings and it is
the question about their serve I can
talk about this at the end but there's
the deserve entropy massages are kind of
and questions you can ask them with
using just entropy and and the model are
serve interesting but setting that aside
first of all you see the fast which does
pretty well and I should mention that
we're using the same amount of yeah okay
sorry it's the it's the percent if you
take the absolute value of the lab so
it's a percent it's the percentage of
the true partition function that the
double okay the difference from the
exact / the exact refraction is a
relative error so these r % just stand
deviation they're on there according to
send their deviation
yes
so a couple a couple points on the
probability on the posterior probability
sure that is yes welcome right we're not
giving I mean I'll show you a graph
later on a couple of points first point
is hostages as well but they all get
worse as we're increasing the variance
so the reason why this is happening is
they're not letting them all converge
obviously if I let them all runs fish
too long they will all converge to the
right answer I'm not cutting this short
pollen gets harder we know the problem
gets harder as you increase the
temperature right there's going to be
less and less for mixing the whole point
of the graph is that we're basically
saying how far along after thousand
samples are you two getting the right
answer but here down in the last column
with 0.7 variance you observed it the
silly method that was actually doing
things separately and supposed to be
worse at all times is doing quite well
and the reason why is doing quite well
is because it's just realizing its
computational time to sample the
distribution of all shapes better
because we have remember we are sampling
the way we're actually estimating the
one of the position function is
basically starting from the University
distribution and slowly annealing into
that to the right distribution to obtain
this function so it's it seems that you
have to be fairly careful about if
you're going to use unyielding port
sampling in some incarnation you have to
be fairly careful how you're going to
use where you're going to put your
computation time arguing to sample which
is really going to sample for how long
we're going to sit and we're going to
spend more time luckily the fast which
does pretty well for us so there's no
need to actually deal with these kind of
issues but overall picking the
taking the the the silliest silliest
method is not necessarily that bad and
all the Shakers help us yes yes you're
ending in Turkish agency
no I have that would
that would that would make a difference
because of the way we're scanning we're
creating the permutation of species
that's that's that's a good point no I
have me financially question could you
look at it in a different way and say if
you just very parameters of these things
which of these parameters would lead to
maximizing for some shape it's not
trying to get a pelicula shave you're
just trying to get a nation as you
smashing earlier it wouldn't be the
right heavenly demise the entropy
memorization of entropy okay so so what
you would get to clump right clump is
very much adored by everything right
it's not that you brought it up it isn't
a and we didn't prepare this beforehand
his own question maybe we should have
last night in the wee hours no practice
again now you will say this anyway if
you could forget about the shape if you
give me a model and you tell me what's
the minimum entropy that's achievable by
this in this model many parameters I can
tell you what is the what is the what is
the best probability you are going to
get for a shape because from the other
side you have the maximum entropy
distribution which is you say well I'll
give you fifty percent for all these
distributions arrest it has to be spread
out uniformly so you can actually see
where you overlap and see how you're
doing it's difficult to obtain that the
minimum entropia estimates for for a
mole although it's obviously it's an
interesting question because if you say
that then you can somebody's coming up
with a lot of small and says it's it's a
rule of thumb it's an excellent one
mistake they made is basically so
computing these things just by sample to
see how often I visit and I was very
happy when I see three percent or
something but then if somebody shows
your results said it was suspicious at
the time how coming in three percent of
some configuration with it's not very
likely that that's the case and then you
have roll the time tells you it's surf
useful for debugging as well all the
time it sells you
you will never exceed this probability
it's pretty pretty strong and serve if
it's extendable to two different models
of two more complicated models you can
actually have theoretical bounds on self
assembly itself involved central you
getting your shape no that's why I'm
saying
oh yeah be the bike which would be there
diagnosed by the followed by the
preceding method and so I just plot just
serve make it more more precise what's
going on so the experiment then the
index I've sorted the settings of the of
the theta parameters based on the exact
partition arity so we have so it's not
the noisy diagram should basically what
you're seeing is now there's no relative
error you're actually am showing you the
actual estimates for four Thetas for the
charges being sampled from the normal
distribution with 0.3 variance so
basically seeing that the blue dots
either for a fall exactly on the on the
red line which is the exact or there at
least disclose their closer than
everybody else and this is all x-axis is
just the experiment index this is how
hundred replicates and I just saw them
to make it make a sword and based on
their sort of based on this a best under
the true probability at throw ratio they
sorbate yeah sorry the exact that's my
index that fine is very otherwise you
would just have noise right even be like
you know it would be very difficult to
actually see what's going on hey whats
next america could see what guy so okay
super ok now we're done this is this
whole effort to compute the
probabilities of shape on to and by the
way I mean the probability of the shape
is the measure of performance there is
no classification there no ROC curves
you want to actually report probability
of the yield essentially of the
particular shape now the question is
obviously you want to pull out
derivatives as well in order to optimize
things so the candidates are the pasta
machine learning role and then we can we
actually do something with this fast
switch because it seems quite promising
right if it can compute the value
correctly most likely will compute the
derivative value fairly well as well and
it's just it's fairly fairly simple you
have just a nice little important
sampling
try going on you take your sampling from
distribution F you were basically
mapping it into configuration dividing
by by this weight that's basically
dividing out the probability which
sample then put it in the right
probability and additionally I don't
need to muck around with the constant
because this is just it's just an
expectation of this value so actually I
do need to make I know I don't need to
my current with the closet this is
sufficient so now we actually want to
compare how well did the know but its
opposite the capacitor it is but that's
the richest will be following I put
myself in the shape and then I take one
particle and tried to move it somewhere
and trying I think another later I take
another particle try to move it
somewhere and explore the local mode but
will not hit the whole distribution
contest the CD free energy is not right
for energy to optimize because
ultimately we want to probability we
want probability of over me and my
neighbors so quite that sort of hands
down win for the fast weight although
not in all yes i have but they don't
have to put the results and it wasn't it
well it's the question is when do you
stop right i mean i can push the
capacitive urgences all these methods
eventually right I Carter various one I
mean in terms of parameters as
contrasted divergence method fine same
primers because I do the burden she will
not know
good you are a chosen right right I
haven't compared that I haven't compared
the I prepare derivative is a derivative
and they're not they're no better than
the the balls patrol but I haven't
compared well if you optimize for a long
enough time that's quite different
difficult to because they can by chance
get into a nice night they have to pour
estimates of derivatives and they sort
of circle their way to right solution
how am I to say that that was really
intentional or not right it's kind of
difficult if you're comparing how well
the optimization performs as the ten
iterations of using serve noisy or
incorrect gradients then you have to
sample pretty a lot 100 iterations of
thousand ten thousand samples and after
that you say this is these are my
primaries I've converse the one you can
they take those parameters and you
compute the
for your best boss which method to
compute the ratio like listen see what
how many times they have to reklame Nora
but that's Lucia how did that that
experiment you have to pay applicate a
lot of times you have to integrate over
all the paths right because they could
have gotten it you know if you do it 10
times it's not enough because they could
have gotten so it has to be a large
number of experience experiments where's
weird river to compare go on comparisons
it's pretty easy are you either getting
right directors or not nice all yeah so
so which is the happy nice fast switch
trick so get yourself a mapping simulate
get that little divorce my BFS
parameters yeah but we have no rotation
and how how more different okay how more
difficult is the is the carbon thing
because it's also a different signal
brain has a structure not as a well it's
in 3d so it's only anymore slightly more
computationally effect if you're talking
about carbon carbon carbon like atoms of
carbon then that really depends on the
potentials so the dist serve to to
having doing the time we did serve wrap
this up this part up where is the main
contributions for the chemistry
community is concerned is that saying
that if you want to optimize the the
yield of a self-signed process you do
that by maximize the probability of the
shape that you want it's a trivial
statement for us it's not trivial
statement for that they're used to
optimizing doing things like finding the
ground shape the sorry current state
there is to actually doing inference
finding local minima they're not used to
designing Waka manner which is what we
do all the time so it's quite a bit of
yes low come in and watch while I and
there's no point the other oki all local
back okay the global minima if you have
a nice enough function which isn't which
is not going to happen here I'm showing
you a couple of methods for for
assessment so computing probabilities
and how how to compute derivatives there
is the nested sampling which I haven't
talked about which is quite certain to
pep it up but it's quite an interesting
method that also doesn't require any
temperature temperature schedules what
it does is if you can isolate a variable
which serve correlates with increase in
energy and has some domain from 0 to 1
you can actually numerically integrate
over that variable sample the states and
all obtain the likelihoods and just do a
number in the medical integration of
what's under the curve that makes sense
it actually turns out to do pretty well
for problems they are known to be
difficult like the computing petition of
the partition function under the
Pottsville which which even the
strengthened wang the best samplers are
served they have talked with mixing so
they will be very very poor in
estimating that the partition function a
particular regime so it's it's quite
promising the only problem is that you
have to find this variable which serving
as it as use you're basically in case
that variable monotonically the energy
goes up I don't have that variable here
you have it in pot small which is the
number of bonds in the pot swallow
number of things they have the same
color if you're the one that way well
number of bonds in this sort of extended
setup of the pot small where you
actually doing this hidden variable so
it's quite how to how to get that method
to actually work to find out if there is
such a variable or to generalize the
nice assembling it's quite it's quite
sort of interesting and and
especially since they don't have the
problems we topped mixing their
hypothesis poor mixing which we saw we
have when I show you the table as the
variance was getting higher we're
getting worse and worse that it took
we're getting reports performance it
takes longer and longer time if we can
actually get them if an acid sampling is
the holy grail of the efficient sampling
in the pot small it might be actually
efficient holy grail you know the
solution for efficient sampling in the
small as well so it's quite promising
anyway so this that the home that this
whole story in this or more diminutive
form was presented the natick insect
conference as a keynote and they were
quite ecstatic and as a result of that
of that I set up a collaboration with
the Cooper lab University of Liverpool
those guys are basically interested in
high-throughput methods for for analysis
of odd systems like the scanning
electron microscope and also
high-throughput synthesis of
nanoparticles of different size between
different capping ligands and so on so
they're they're served their part of
that loop that I was talking about it
basically did more difficult potentially
part of the loop where they actually do
the experiments automatically and they
synthesis materials and automatically
all that is neither is the guiding hand
of machine learning to actually make
this into a great sort of
self-sustaining material design system
so the in the in the future question is
I've shown you how to optimize I have
given myself a full reign of any kind of
charges I can do whatever I want right
that's that that basically tells me sir
put the demand on the chemists to say
when I tell him these are the charges
that are going to maximize the
self-assembly now you produce a particle
and serve that they're saying that they
can because they can put all kinds of
different peptides on top of the golden
or on the gold nanoparticle but the
question is if should we pursue this
problem in a different take a different
tack and say well there is 20 species I
say amino acids can we actually optimize
with the preset species optimized what
their
they should be to actually pursue this
problem and I have done something
similar something related to this in the
workers doing and design on the protein
has set receptors but it's it's it's
essentially a variational method so it's
not exactly it's not not a lower bound
of things so I served I set aside and it
wouldn't be enough time to talk about
anyway but to those who are going to
talk to me okay we can chat about it as
well and in terms of computers computer
science proper there is a related
problem it has similar flavors this a
problem of designing self-stabilizing
systems and this is important in the it
in basically design designing
distributed systems where you have very
basis they'd have to be resilient to any
kind of crashes so you have to actually
cover fairly quickly subsidization
refers to the ability to recover to a
legal state in finite number of steps so
if you purposes and get it to go to a
bad stating back get back to the legal
stuff elia fairly quickly so this is not
not an equilibrium thing you're not
allowed infinite amount of time to clear
its you actually have to do this in
finite time so it's quite clear very
difficult difficult problem but similar
it has a similar flavor so methods might
be applicable to it as well any
questions before I serve skip ahead so
it seems like it might be hard right to
you this is all 2d on a very small
lattice with right and you've assumed
the orientation is fixed which would I
mean just we take if we allow the
orientation to vary actually if I get
better performance if you log rotation
but by the amount you have to
ok I just I wouldn't be able to give you
the exact numbers for a dissertation
boost my my even if is the the
complexity way too much for me yeah baby
I just am very skeptical that you can
scale this up the problems that are
interesting in well you can buy the same
trick that well the argument is that you
can because if you actually add if you
get to the first of all so the question
is the problem of mixing essentially is
that what you're saying that we can in
confessional e sample the state space
family for the entire state spaces the
state space is huge it's it's hard it's
hard yes
pretty small say face
it's not clear if the face face is well
they're there to answer first of all can
you actually approximate large state
space with bit small how big is how how
big a shape are you talking about
because that's sort of determining your
lattice because we could do the boundary
are fairly about a boundary effects we
can do put the boundary to emulate
larger space but if your shape is
sufficiently big so you have a large
shape you have to fit in bladders then
prom yes so essentially you're saying
what is the issue with how good a mixing
a beginning and I'm not addressing that
I mean a sensitive mixing gets gets
worse but I haven't they haven't really
used I have not done all my steps or
gibbs sampler steps so I'm not annealing
anything I'm aside for for particular
from that one method when I'm kneeling
in surf rather fairly straightforward
way and are using anything very
sophisticated so point taken it's a
vertical question whether it will
actually works
that's a polite what he actually
supposed to look good too if you get to
the Cooper lab then you don't have to if
you give me a scanning or if you give me
a picture of the Istanbul then you can
throw away the inference right you give
me a picture of the state space and a
large they're basically whole huge swath
of space where you actually have all
this particles assembled that you
basically made my inference very much
easier I can do contrasted divergence
example around that's the state if you
want so that's that so in a sense
additional yes I mean I guess that
presupposes it seems like those are
different problem because I mean if you
could actually get an SEM picture of the
result and you're going to think I
already set up this experiment
I can tell you about the probability of
certain configurations having haven't
given that picture as opposed to saying
that like I know I'm just making a
substrate like this and just wanting to
see what are the probabilities of
different states I'm hearing maybe I i
I'm not sure I understand but that let
me try it serve a stab in the dark
answer we do this in in in the loop
right sure that seems kind of
impractical we want to tell if they're
doing pick understands the day they
don't have enough enough stuff to do
anyway so really I'm sure they'd do they
would agree with me but if they're going
to Terrence cans a day and they asked
for a picture and then said they sent me
this love so obviously they have
problems taking and taking the picture
could be part of the right right right
right I see this issue of computing
yield doesn't strike me that yield is a
necessarily good measure not all errors
are created equal especially in this
space if you're going to do tubes for
example a hole I devastating whereas a
couple extra you know thickness here
right you cared what so you're basically
saying that in shape definition should
be a little bit allow more leeway so i
can define probably cricket yield of a
different kind of shape i don't have to
be restrictive to what kind of shapes
and could be a probability up there
could be a very large number of
acceptable shape
right so you went to find them the
surface popping ah saying that defining
all the shapes might be a difficult task
so if you sure they would have to be
done implicitly something right friends
we know I agree I agree you can actually
but you at the end of the day you have
to define some predicate sort of
sampling division people are they what
they play with the but if levity in your
importance function they play with that
and they put some mulling into that say
well
yeah it's something he's sort of pretty
lonely it's relatively with that he put
it in the interesting process yeah what
we're scaling functions I mean it have
to be somewhere you can pick what you're
going to sample from but you would have
to be you know the only thing but we may
we may actually well but the consumer
they make it different email is like the
example the david ray is just like you
might want to know the probability of
there being no holes that might be the
things you really care about as opposed
to their but that all i think that it's
it right that also the case the same
problem though right but some states
have 0 boots but it's a generalization
of the other the scores yeah at the end
of the day I'm saying is you will
compute probability of the subset now
how are you going to define a subset and
they are their difficulties with that
yeah sure had no problem with that had a
complete agree okay so skipping along
we're not skipping all but moving along
with it deserves did I spend all my time
I I will be very I will give the cuts of
thing I give you pictures so the task is
very swiftly task is basically give me
input-output pairs for which you want me
to find a program i find a program for
you some of you awesome other people
play claim to actually do the same thing
and they did with the genetic programs
but it only works for functional
programs functional programs don't have
any notion of the state so if you make a
bit to pro change somewhere in the
program it doesn't affect that's the
program just are going to fax that that
particular expression that's not how
most of the programs today in the world
I've written unless you're writing
Haskell allow a scope but this is not
most code is basically an imperative
languages so this district is not going
to work and so we actually have to deal
with the imperative programs we have to
deal with the notion of the state and
what we're going to do is our sir put a
probabilistic spin on the whole thing
we're going to redefine what an
instruction is we're going to introduce
probabilistic instruction then this
instruction is just basically a mixture
of all possible structures with certain
probabilities so we actually in this
case we actually have three instructions
to each we are assigning certain
probability that's this is the full
adjustment should make that point this
is the fooled instruction set it to each
instruction we assign certain
probability and then we were just
basically asking well what happens if i
apply this that this now probabilistic
instruction to a particular state and
you see that the following state
probability of variable unassuming
petition but work particular value is
basically equal to sum of all the
instructions that would map into that
value so just basically the formal set
up set of instructions set of possible
states and basically efficient
probabilistic instruction as a
multinomial and basically have this
transition definition that basically if
you give me a state and you give me some
distributional instructions to all in
order to compute the probability of the
next day that is basically integrator
all the instructions and find which is
the structure is actually map if this
thing fairly safe or especially only
have seven minutes probabilistic
programs probability programs if you
just as generalize this idea basically
going to put a whole lot of instructions
one after another and each of them is
again multinomial so you're going to
have lots of plenty of instructions each
is basically a distribution or
instructions and what you want to now go
back to our task we have input-output
pairs and we want to basically find it
for another maps inputs to outputs so we
want to find we want to maximize the
joint probability of all the inputs
being map to all the outputs so
essentially we're going to integrate
over all the programs all the possible
state sequences and integrate them out
to obtain this probability to do this
exactly obviously is impossible when
it's possible then you get right
solution right away because a nice
little Donette program and mainly
because you're sharing the program if we
had cyber cop is a program no problem
easy but we don't want that we wanted
one program to solve all the all the
input-output pairs so we have to
approximate this and how we approximate
well we're going to use the service
possible selves as simple as possible
approximation technique which is the
loopy belief propagation we
setting up here factor graph all we have
to care about here given the distinction
of time this is state sequence for a
particular execution of the program for
one input output pair this is another
state sequence for different input
output pair and this is the shared
program belief propagation works out the
way it actually works out all the time
and just serve to illustrate if we have
more input-output pairs which will
actually have then we're going to have
more and more these lines you've seen
the cylinder so each line represents is
basically an equivalent of one of these
state sequences so pretty easy stuff so
now we actually that token problem of
fitting polynomials given a finite
length of the program and we obviously
going to take a fairly simple so the
instructions be fab multiply add the
multiple variables at the constant
multiple constant or set variable and
we're going to cap to keep some
registers have to find at fit the
polynomials of this type over some
finite domain so we're going to have
integers up certain after modular
certain number so if you just apply the
factory after I showed you to all the
all the polynomials where you basically
just can choose whether or one factor in
front of each of the edge of the
monomials what you get is that you can
actually solve sent five percent of the
prawns and then the difficulties arise
and one case this problematic is this
xtube in particular domain obviously X
cubed domain is from zero this is the
module five and the difficulty is that
the actual output that resembles a
mixture of two possible outputs of very
very simple programs so I'm here the key
point here being is that all the program
in this set up the way I've shown you
right now all the programs are not
equated equally all all input-output
pairs are not created equally there's
plenty of ways to do nothing there's
plenty of ways to real as you know up
can I have 0 x 1 or you can just
multiply before couple
so what happens is that if you can find
two solutions which have high
multiplicity there's high entropy a sign
associated with this particular with
program like these the program x + 1
they soup up a lot of probability mass
and the Sakura spawning states that
Superman a lot of probability mess and
you end up with that with weird
solutions which are basically mixtures
of solutions for these two programs and
furthermore you can actually because you
can replete this multiplication by for
several times and each time you get and
then when you repeat it twice you get
indentity mapping you're pretty much in
solution in a position that at any given
point you can just alternate these two
instructions and gather correct program
so what we need to do is basically ah
reduce one thing to do is basically to
try to serve even out this multiplicity
so to make number roughly speaking make
the number of programs that do in
density it XD or x + 1 roughly equal to
the number of programs that actually are
performing computing X cubed plus 1 so
we have to add constraints and
constraints there a couple of
constraints we have tried and I think
they're all listed here constraints you
can easily put on the states and you can
put also constraints on the on the
instruction sequences of instructions
and the constraint on the states are
essentially that you don't really want
to repeat unless you have solved
particular you have you have actually
reached the point that you have the
correct output in the state there is no
point to repeat the step in the state
there's no point applying the same
instruction over and over again there's
no point in repeating the state and
there's no point in actually creating
knob constructs like this multiplication
before so there's number of these
constraints they can actually apply
which actually as far as the constraint
like nope is concerned which seller
seems a little contrived you can
actually given the instructions and
given that the manner which we were
working on you can actually figure out
for certain length what are all the
combinations they actually produce
enough
effect and try to suppress them so once
we actually had an ordinary constraints
for instructions then obviously loosely
the multiplicity of knobs because you
can basically beat and we can repeat the
same instructional sorry no repeat
constraint on it that was correct or
incorrect no repeat construct constraint
on the states we reduce multiplicity of
knob programs and the once you add this
constraint you actually obtain solution
for all the polynomials of this type
again whatever I am saying is the ABC
and D is actually 0 ones and we will try
this over small domains where module
five models module seven in module 13 so
fairly easy problem what's what's this
is what's but what's important is to
notice basically that we have we are
actually fitting a function we are
restricting the complexity of the
function Kolmogorov complexity
understanding you have to have seven
instructions you can't learn say I look
up table because we don't have room for
drupal and booked up table you actually
have to find a code the maps the
simplest examples so then we are
wondering well they have believed prop
works so maybe the other stuff works
maybe it's an easy problem that's been
easy problem so the third propagation is
a method of the sum of your most you're
familiar with certification basically
solves the case a problem fairly well
for a certain set of sad problems and
then the question is well if you take
this state machine and stay take all
this constraints that you actually
translate the the execution of the
machine data for the abstract machine
into into a SAT formula which is sort of
fairly standard thing that said that
things have been done for the Turing
machine obviously you can do it here and
turn that in turn this form into
basically a sad problem and fill the
survey propagation you can do anything
it cannot even connect to States tree
along the basically three states and so
one time just one
instruction to map from the input to
from the starting to the ending state so
the problem is that we actually have a
whole whole lot of constraints basically
on the on on the variables we're saying
the variable can only be in one state
and for each variable I'll skip the
other alternative solution and just
basically moved to the second problem
second problem is basically that of the
list reversal so we're looking at a
third repro problems we actually want to
iterate to a certain number of we go to
certain other iterations and basically
flip around the list so i won't go into
details of this so the fact you got the
setup of the fat graph is is such so
that we actually now we have certain
small number of instructions which are
basically connected to a particular
state in each in each iteration so it's
basically instruction number 1 is
connected is basically influencing
mapping from from 0 to the first state
and then after in the next iteration
from the third to the fourth state so we
basically unroll the loop and connect
these structures there to to appropriate
state and the when we actually try to do
just again with the plane with a plane
factory without actually find a program
that actually does this on the structure
set again that didn't work the solving
again we need to do that need to add the
constraint and the solving constraint
actually is all the issues here is the
one that forces the states to get closer
and closer to the end to the output so
that they're in each iteration more and
more states are actually equivalent to
the output which is what you actually
would expect from a for loop or a little
iterative programs in general you solve
the problem for the first entry in the
array and you set it to some value then
you move to the second entry there in
the rain and so on so essentially in all
this problem in all the three problems
your progress is incremental and you
didn't get getting closer and closer to
the final state now if you actually add
functionals there that are included
increasing power increasing serve
suppression of the wrong states in the
variables of our more states after
actually be closer to the final output
state you obtain the program down here
which you will have to believe me does
actually reverse reverse a list so
what's the what actually well what what
happened and what what's going to happen
so I actually associated on fella to two
examples I actually can infer for value
difficult problem is you're just doing
the input-output pairs you want to I
want to defer the program so that the
step serve forward a slightly different
problem where you actually have to
correct existing piece of code add a
couple of instructions so that you
satisfied more than additional set of
input outlet pairs so it's already
working on some inputs it has a bug and
doesn't work on a particular one couple
of in pairs can you find instruction
that actually changes this it's an
easier problem in the sense that we
actually have a good initialization we
already have a program that works for
everything so we're already in local
mini mall you want to do is shift
slightly and to improve the code another
application is basically trying to infer
multi to the code not deterred
applications or not the Mafia code where
you actually have multiple threads
communicate at the same time in working
we actually have initial on the final
state that's quite a bit more
complicated but it's served one of a
possible future application additional
applications in the domain of the
program languages is assumed is
basically this translation validation is
where a problem that's submit
application somebody suggested that
where we actually have compiler
generating two versions of code one is
optimum optimized demise and optimizing
you want to basically prove that that or
to compile generating to cope at verses
of the code you want to actually show
that the these two piece of code a coin
so what you actually how you do it in
general is basically run both pieces of
both the compiled versions on the same
inputs and see what they produce the
same out but another option is to
basically try and figure out what the
optimizations optimizations are that are
actually transferred transferring
transforming the one copy of the
compiled code into another so in a sense
you're trying to find the program that
maps to success the optimization maps on
product on
program an additional interesting
application is the discovery of the
invariants in front of program traces so
this is sort of slightly but slightly
different we're actually looking for a
predicate that holds across all the
traces and this predicate it the input
output divided is slightly blurred here
because you're actually looking for a
relation that maps that the holds across
the board and you would actually want it
just in order to summarize the execution
of the program or use the summarization
for the Fertile Crescent tri-state for
the for the analysis ordained
interpreted procedure analysis because
once you know that behavior of the of
the state space in the procedure you can
make inferences about how that state
space is going to behave and it can
actually prove for make it up make
assertions about the other interacting
pieces of code that actually depend on
the state space or the procedure okay so
that would serve fairly Swift zooming
kick me hit why why yeah what was the
point the point is that i've added you
know what's the motivation behind be
healthier so i failed ok to explain
motivation is the to automate the
correction of the code give me a puppy
this whole session you start off just
saying I mean learn well grams and their
weird programs cuts right through this
very small field and they have this very
limited number of instructions and so
why do I care about learning
and a lot of problems you ran into had
to do the fact that you're learning
integer programs in a small field right
if these have been real well I want real
valued functions and then I want depend
a lot of these these particular problems
that you ran into okay so first why the
wonky problems why the small small field
because it's small we can actually do
inference we can figure out whether it's
working on that so why do I have type
problems is her account of their initial
questions they have one type on to see
if what's the one of the methods that
what would actually work on this I agree
if we had more if we had a real domain
I've had large domain that would be
easier but the inference will be much
more expensive so we were actually
trying out methods that actually do this
and it's not clear to me that the
problems in the real world are actually
of the Kiley's you're suggesting and not
of a wonky type where we have issues
with small domains wait the goal is
really nice too not necessarily to fill
these functions automatic pay well now's
a fixed buggy code that was right right
well but that's what what yeah tied to
but josh sir if you're actually the
testers are basically just telling you
what's working what's not
I just gonna give this is what it failed
they come think of it think of this as
the running up just automatic that fix
the code yeah these are in some sense
harder than that questions we just
started with this to figure out how far
you can get with just machine learning
without of additional ization and buggy
code is a traditional asian that should
allow it we sort of clearly perturb the
quarantine fix the coronary
so that's one of the qualifications but
they're probably some spaces where you
could actually do the job automatically
without having a really long pizza like
for instance balance checking and
defense right so you basically have you
could propose different vowels checking
things feet at a bunch of example
quickly find out that the caja you know
i answered these particular spell checks
then I no longer fail and that would be
a really useful common
oh can I think I did it is to fix the
parts that are there too silly they're
easy but they take time yeah so so the
it is you you write physical quickly and
it kind of works and just I decided to
test a trusting you with healthy late
fails of these calculations and instead
the transition or you should just press
the button like that personal case it is
fixing the problem and then you're done
so that's nothing
a lot of implications takes but a
degenerate while ago it's very
interesting thinking this in terms of
function addiction with complexity of
regularization
adesso organization typically it's true
complexity regularization how difficult
is it to explain this function
it's just we're just looking at what
what's the can we solve can we solve
problems on essentially this should be
easy is it easily solvable right it
seems like they're easy problems so we
shouldn't have any difficulty with that
and we basically testing out a little
bit really propagation on this problem
not necessarily saying this is the form
that from now on everybody has to solve
it always mayhem will occur which is how
to use it
so what situation is as you mentioned
that if the program are kind of
identifies it is a bug in a small part
of the port and then we can we just take
me into well there is simpler will give
a good initial initially as you
suggesting and you can try to modify
that thing to get close to the bread put
another scenario may be that we have to
say different versions of the code so
and all of those agents have a different
kind of time so I had some version of
the food and I probably I want to fix
some bug but in I introduce about the
bug in the new version and then can we
take those modules together and try to
identify required program that is the
fish to me on this scenario
stop okay thanks